you guys obviously you had to work a
million jobs before you you hit it did
you what kind of jobs were you working
before like like in the workings yeah
the jobs I I loaded pallets at a
warehouse for a place called zaires
which is like a precursor to Target I
remember sure yeah I do my Christmas
shopping instead there you go and uh and
then uh we uh to uh uh make ends meet I
was painting the houses when I was
trying to get booked I could cut in
pretty good yeah yeah you could get it
kind of that line and get that through
the line and if you could do the line
you didn't have to do all the rolling
right sure did the line yeah smart
and Melissa you worked at Starbucks I
did were you were you were you good at
that job
I was I kind of you know it had there
was like it kept you busy and the time
went on um it was in Santa Monica so
when I first moved here I didn't have a
car so I had to have jobs that I could
walk to so I worked at the Y and I
worked at Starbucks where I saw oh
um I think we're weirdly just talking
about this because I have a picture in
my dressing room but uh I Chris Farley
came in and I was so I'm so excited
because he looms pretty largely for me
and so I kept trying to think of like
because you can tell he just wanted to
they want everybody to make a fuss and
so I in my
poorly executed way of like don't freak
him out I just kept staring at him
at the point I got so overwhelmed
because he was right there that I
started crying
and so I was just standing there like
making him this coffee and I know I was
like stop locking on it like I was so I
was so locked on him I was just like
and now I'm starting to cry and then
it's like I wonder now if when I gave
him that coffee if he just went outside
and was like um
and I just wanted to say like I love you
so much and instead are you good now
that uh things have changed for you are
you good at meeting Heroes now
no I'm awkward
I'm naturally I'm naturally here's how I
feel when you meet people that inspire
you especially
I just I can't take the disappointment
if if you've been inspiring me for a lot
of years please please don't be that
Hollywood douche yeah
more chances
[Music]
I didn't know I got it I said shine my
shoes
and I did because I want the job I am I
got the I had the luxury of meeting for
Springsteen yeah and uh oh my God I was
so overwhelmed she literally was
grabbing my arm going breathe breathe
because I came to one of our tapings and
I just blurted out when I'm like please
don't be an I won't be able to
take it
you were in a full we were sitting at
the kitchen table on our set and Jimmy
Burns who directed us at the left waited
till literally he was just about to yell
action ran in right in front of Billy's
face and goes look who's here yeah and
pointed just when you could do your
scene right because he thought it was
hilarious and literally Billy goes
and began like weird breathing where I
thought hyperventilating this may not
actually be okay like I have it's like
grabbing his arm and I was like focus on
me you pull it together because he's
like he's gonna go he's gonna hide he's
gonna pass out and he's gonna pass out
in front of Bruce and he'll never give
himself focus on me not Bruce
Springsteen catch a priority straight
thank God because I couldn't then when I
met him I just I just sounded so stupid
for the first 20 minutes yeah a lot of
good songs that you see nothing
in this thing you can say
you made music for people
you're done yeah there's nothing you can
do